donde nos quedamos en el último vídeo
esta vamos aproximando una función
efe de que depende de dos variables de
entrada verdad y terminamos con esta
expresión de aquí que parece muy
monstruosa y debido esto es debido a que
está escrita en su forma abstracta
verdad de hecho se ve más monstruosa de
lo que en realidad es así que haremos un
ejemplo particular y sólo para recordar
qué significa cada cosa q es nuestra
aproximación cuadrática alrededor de x 0
y 0 verdad y este digamos es el término
constante de nuestra aproximación es
simplemente evaluar
efe en el punto que nos interesa luego
aquí tenemos los términos que son
lineales verdad y son lineales porque
estamos pensando en una constante
multiplicada por x y otra constante
multiplicada por y aunque ya sabemos por
qué restamos x cero ig-0 en ambos en
ambos términos verdad y luego tenemos
todo esto de aquí que son los términos
cuadráticas verdad y son cuadráticas
porque aquí tenemos un exponente 2 aquí
tenemos la multiplicación de x
y aquí tenemos otro exponente 2 estamos
pensando en las posibles
multiplicaciones entre x y de verdad
puede ser x x xx por ye yé porque es
verdad así que ahora veamos un ejemplo
muy concreto para que te des cuenta de
que en realidad no es tan horrible como
parece muy bien así que vamos a
considerar esta función particular fx y
igual a a a la x medios por el seno de y
sólo para que quede claro esto es el
seno de g muy bien entonces vamos a
tratar de sacar toda esta información
que nos pide la función q para poder
expresar la aproximación cuadrática y
por supuesto que lo primero que tenemos
que hacer es definir un punto en donde
alrededor del cual vamos a aproximar y
vamos a considerar el punto cero y
medios muy bien cero porque pues tenemos
un exponente por aquí verdad entonces
sea la 0 sería algo como 1 y pi medios
porque podemos evaluar senodep y medios
coseno de medios y todas las derivadas
verdad entonces primero lo que lo que
tenemos que hacer verdades es es
calcular todas las derivadas parciales
de f hasta digamos las segundas
derivadas parciales verdad entonces
vamos a bajar todo esto y calculamos
primero la derivada con respecto de x de
verdad en cualquier punto ahorita vamos
a hacerlo en cualquier punto y entonces
tenemos aquí este término a la equis
medios esto es depende de y esto es una
constante y al derivar respecto de x
tenemos que derivar esto que es un medio
ea la equis entre dos por la regla de la
cadena verdad por el seno de y ahora si
nosotros calculamos la derivada con
respecto de y de esta expresión verdad
entonces esto es ahora lo que es
constante y esto depende de verdad
entonces tendremos a la equis medios que
es constante por la derivada del seno de
iu
coseno de muy bien ahora vamos a
calcular las segundas derivadas
parciales verdad entonces vamos a
hacerlo con otro color y vamos a
calcular la segunda derivada de f con
respecto de x ambas veces es decir
tenemos que derivar esta expresión
verdad entonces si derivamos esta
expresión vemos que otra vez lo único
que depende de x es esto verdad entonces
tendremos que derivar esto y tendremos
un cuarto verdad sería un medio por la
derivada de x medio es verdad que sería
entonces un cuarto por ea la x medios
todo esto es por regla de la cadena y y
es muy fácil concluir la verdad y bueno
como esto es constante en realidad se
queda aquí verdad multiplicando ahora
tenemos la derivada de f con respecto a
x y luego con respecto a iu y por
supuesto como ya hemos dicho en realidad
como esta función digamos es de las que
casi siempre estamos considerando pues
podemos invertir el orden verdad podría
haber sido la derivada respecto de jay y
luego con respecto de x
pero vamos a hacer primero respecto de
equis que ya lo tenemos calculado aquí y
ahora vamos a derivar esto con respecto
de y entonces esto es una constante y
solo hay que derivar seno de ella
entonces tendríamos un medio a la equis
medios por la derivada del seno de jay
que es co seno de iu muy bien y
finalmente vamos a considerar la segunda
derivada de f con respecto de ambas
veces es decir vamos ahora a derivar
esta expresión y como podemos ver lo
único que depende de qué es esto
entonces lo demás es una constante a la
x medios verdad por la derivada del
coseno de ye que es menos el seno de iu
- el seno de iu bien y ahora vamos a
ahora vamos a evaluar en el punto que
hemos dicho verdad que es en el punto
cero coma
i
bien vamos a evaluar en este punto vamos
a hacerlo con color rojo entonces si
nosotros evaluamos en 0 p medios aquí
tendríamos a la 0 que es una verdad por
el seno de pi medios que es 1 entonces
uno por uno nos da 1
si ahora evaluamos esta derivada parcial
con respecto a x en 0 y medios tendremos
un medio por el acero que es 1 x senodep
y medios que es uno entonces esto nos da
justamente un medio verdad un medio por
uno por uno si evaluamos ahora esto en
cero y medios tendremos a la cero que es
uno por el coseno depp y medios por el
coseno depp y medios es cero entonces
esto nos da cero
muy bien ahora evaluamos esta segunda
derivada en 0 y medios y tendremos un
cuarto por el acero que es 1 por el seno
de pi medios que es 1 entonces esto es
sólo un cuarto ahora evaluamos esta
segunda derivada parcial verdad en 0 y
medios tendríamos un medio por el acero
que es 1 por el coseno de cero y esto es
0 verdad coseno de 0 es cero entonces
realmente no importa cuánto daba lo
demás y ahora si evaluamos esta última
en 0 y medios tendremos menos a la 0 que
es 1 por el seno de 0 que también es 1
entonces en realidad al multiplicarlo
nos da menos 1 muy bien ya que tenemos
las seis constantes podemos escribir la
expresión digamos la expresión de la
aproximación cuadrática verdad entonces
vamos a escribir esto aquí tendremos
de xe y quizás vamos a tener que estar
subiendo y bajando verdad entonces
recuerden muy bien cuál es la expresión
q de xy verdad es justamente esta
expresión entonces tendremos que hacer
efe luego los términos lineales y luego
la parte cuadrática muy bien entonces q
de x 2 quizás vamos a dejarlo por aquí q
de que sería evaluar efe en el punto
verdad que sería entonces 1
uno más la derivada parcial de f con
respecto de x evaluada en el punto que
es un medio verdad un medio por x menos
en la coordenada x del punto que nos
interesa que era 0 verdad luego sumamos
la derivada con respecto de ya que es 0
0 que multiplica a menos de 0 que en
este caso sería y medias verdades es la
coordenada y del punto que nos interesa
muy bien ahí tenemos los términos
lineales y ahora vamos con los términos
cuadra ticos entonces si recordamos los
términos cuadra ticos es un medio por la
segunda derivada de f verdad entonces
vamos a poner un medio por la segunda
derivada de f con respecto de x ambas
veces que es un cuarto un cuarto por x
menos la coordenada x 0 que es 0 verdad
esto elevado al cuadrado y nos faltan
otros términos verdad nos falta el
término cruzado
qué es este la segunda derivada cruzada
evaluada en el punto que nos da 0 pero
aún así vamos a ponerlo 0 por x menos la
coordenada del punto que nos interesa
que es 0 verdad por qué menos la
que es para medios verdad ahí tenemos el
término cruzado y finalmente nos falta
el término donde derivamos a efe con
respecto a ambas veces entonces sería un
medio sería un medio por la segunda
derivada de f respecto de ambas veces
evaluada en el punto que es menos 1 que
multiplica hay menos y medios y medios
elevado esto al cuadrado muy bien
entonces esta expresión todavía
podríamos digamos simplificar la más
verdad esto sería igual a 1
un medio por x que es x sobre 2 + 0 por
lo que sea esto en realidad no importa
esto es 0 verdad y luego tenemos un
medio por un cuarto es un octavo de x
cuadrada verdad x cuadradas sobre 8
porque aquí estamos restando de 0 y
luego tenemos 0 por esta expresión que
nos da 0 y finalmente tenemos un medio
por menos 1 sería menos un medio que
multiplica hay menos y medios elevado al
cuadrado y entonces aquí tenemos
justamente nuestra expresión de la
aproximación cuadrática de la función f
en el punto cero pin medios y podemos
notar que a pesar de tener más términos
en realidad es mucho más sencilla de
estudiar que la función que teníamos
originalmente verdad aquí tenemos la x
en una exponencial y en una función
trigonométricas y como podemos ver aquí
simplemente tenemos un polinomio
cuadrática verdad entonces esto por
ejemplo para las computadoras es muy
útil porque tienen
los problemas a la hora de evaluar
digamos los polinomios que las funciones
exponenciales o trigonométricas verdad
incluso para cuestiones teóricas es más
fácil estudiar digamos polinomios verdad
en este caso sería un polinomio
cuadrática que la función original y ya
veremos esto cuando estemos estudiando
el criterio de la segunda derivada y
sólo para dar una idea de qué significa
esto pongamos las gráficas aquí tenemos
la gráfica de la función original ea la
equis entre dos por el seno de iu y el
punto donde queremos aproximar que es x
igual a cero y igual la pyme dios'
entonces aquí vemos más o menos la
orientación y tenemos la aproximación
cuadrática verdad que tiene una gráfica
que se de más o menos así como esta
superficie blanca y si quitamos la
gráfica original entonces aquí está la
gráfica de la aproximación cubo y vemos
que hace un muy buen trabajo verdad si
nos alejamos mucho aún así se sigue
pareciendo aunque no tenga la oscilación
que le corresponde por el seno de verdad
de la función original y tampoco tiene
crecimiento exponencial d
crecimiento cuadrática y como veremos
más adelante esto es es una gran
herramienta para estudiar las
características cualitativas de la forma
de la gráfica como el hecho de que se
vea como una especie de silla de montar
y antes de entrar en estos detalles en
los próximos vídeos hablaré de una forma
más simple y que se puede generalizar de
cómo escribir la aproximación cuadrática
usando la notación vectorial porque
hasta ahora sólo nos hemos limitado a
dos variables y bueno ya te imaginas
cargas que que tan monstruoso se puede
poner si tuviéramos tres variables de
entrada donde tendríamos que considerar
todas las derivadas parciales de una
función de tres variables pero para
suerte nuestra hay una forma muy simple
de escribir todo esto bueno con esto
dicho nos vemos en el próximo vídeo